that's our quarterback and uh i mean
we're
so fired up about him and uh you know
him leading us in the future and
uh you know it's like i said we're
focused week to week
uh right now on getting better each week
and
certainly we're fired up about our
future with that
you feel pretty strongly that mike is
the guy going into 2021
regardless of how the rest of this
season plays out
absolutely unequivocable
i'm reminded of the opening statement
from joe pesci and my cousin vinnie
where he stands up and says everything
that guy just said is
bull crap thank you he didn't say crap
what i'd like to say is everything that
guy just said
could be bullcrap thank you
they're not bound by any of this they're
not bound by saying that dax our
quarterback and he's going to be our
quarterback well in the future they're
not bound by saying
mike mccarthy will unequivocally be back
next year back in 2010
jerry jones said that there was no way
no how he was going to fire wade
phillips during the season
and then he fired wade phillips during
the season the next week when it happens
nobody wags a finger especially not in
post-truth america
nobody's going to say you but you said
sir
that you would not be firing your cat no
we
we cover the event we move on so look
i'm not complaining about having content
we talked about this on pftpm last night
this is what we do we cover the sport
but i don't believe it for a second
i'm not saying it won't happen i'm just
saying whether or not
it does or doesn't happen either as to
dak or has to mccarthy
whether or not it happens has no
relationship whatsoever to what stephen
jones said yesterday
period well i i i get that all right so
i don't know if i totally agree with you
there
i i agree with you on mike mccarthy i
think that like is still going to be
uh evaluated through this process and i
don't think dallas is one to kind of
just cut the court after a year i really
do believe them and they want to like
play the the long play here and build
something with mccarthy
man with dak prescott mike i mean well i
i mean i feel like they're cornered i
mean
first off of course they're excited
about having him back now they realize
how awesome he is
i mean that's the first thing they're
gonna go damn you know he's better than
we thought he was
because we are absolute crap crap crap
when he's not here playing for us whoa
at least we were offensively explosive
when he was here
even without a run game or all that but
the other thing is
man they're gonna look real like some
real jerks down there
if they don't at least make a franchise
offer to dak prescott coming off that
severity of the injury what if their
position
gets trevor lawrence what if what if
what if they end up
at the top of the draft order yeah would
you take
trout would you take would you take dak
prescott paying him 37 million plus next
year under the franchise tag or trevor
lawrence with a four-year contract
that would be less than 37 million for
all four years combined i'd probably
take trevor lawrence
i probably would okay but that's
probably about it it has to be trevor
lawrence all right
and that i don't say that lightly
because i think dak prescott is one of
the six or seven best quarterbacks in
football
top eight i mean he's somewhere in that
range he is
i don't care what anybody says it might
not be sexy and
it lacks like you know like cool flair
when he throws it and all that stuff but
either way the results are sexy
and then he hangs in there and he's
tough and all that but like trevor
lawrence is the only guy mike
i mean i don't think any like the justin
fields the kids up in north dakota state
no way there's some other guys that i
know are going to be in this
conversation too
but i just don't think uh you can easily
part ways with a guy like dak prescott
he's too
talented and that is an injury that you
know
i know it was serious but i do think
he'll be very close to getting back to
100
is not going to affect the rest like
long-term part of his career
chris what's the point though in taking
that card off the table now there's got
to be a way to stick handle through the
verbal minefield
to not disrespect dac but also
close the door on the possibility why do
you do it
if because look let's say that
that you do get the trevor lawrence pick
part of your leverage to get the
ultimate value in trading it
is to create the impression that you
want him one of the reasons why the
dolphins were
offering the bengals whatever they
ultimately offered is the bengals wanted
joe burrow right
if if the bengals had put out the word
that they're committed to andy dalton
would have been a hell of a lot easier
to pry that pick away from the
cincinnati bengals so sometimes your
best leverage is
yeah he's our guy you get more that way
so i
i just think and and look i i know
and this is one of the dangers of doing
these radio interviews if you're stephen
jones or jerry jones you're going to get
yourself into a spot
where while speaking extemporaneously
you're going to say something you're
going to have to deal with later
but i just i don't i don't like removing
options when you're a bad team that
could end up with the top pick and could
end up with a chance to get trevor
lawrence yeah
i i i understand that now but
you know what if okay now you're gonna
be the number three pick right let's
just
let's just say the jets do get number
one and the jaguars are number two
i mean when the season's over what are
you gonna do what are you gonna do with
dak you're gonna offer him the franchise
tag at least right to start off there
right right but we don't know what pick
they're gonna have
that's the thing why close doors now it
makes no sense to close doors now and
say that dak
and the other thing too is this is the
great disconnect that the cowboys
continue to engage in with dak prescott
they say all the glowing positive things
about him like
that's a replacement for paying him like
we really love dak and he's our future
well then why in the hell didn't you
give him a contract offer the moment
that the window opened
to sign him to a long-term deal instead
of screwing around and almost said a
word other than screwing around
for the last three years while his
leverage keeps going up and it keeps
getting more and more expensive and
they're still doing it chris
they they have been over a barrel
because they've put themselves there
with all the things they've said about
dak
well they definitely haven't helped
their cause i mean yes
but also i mean we know they did make a
good offer to him
he just wasn't enough wasn't to his
liking yeah i think that's the that's
where
it went off the rails a little bit
anybody i know with knowledge of the
situation it seems like dallas thought
dak would take a little less to be the
quarterback of the cowboys i think
that's what dallas thought
the jones family and it came time and
dax said hey i like you guys
nothing personal but this is business
and i'm not taking less for nobody
sorry so now you're proven my point
nothing personal this is business we
have to evaluate all of our options
right you have to see what happens
okay but mike like you said who cares if
he says this now and does he doesn't
want a firestorm he's got enough issues
in dallas he doesn't want to start
talking about
now we're gonna get rid of dak prescott
and go to trevor lawrence so
yeah like we see he said what he had to
say okay he moves on i think they
believe in dak
right but we'll see what that happens if
they have that number one pick i bet you
that'll make them reassess mike like
you're saying my point is you you don't
want to complicate your effort to get
maximum value if you truly do believe
that dax the guy
because now you're gonna have to deal
with that when negotiating with some
other team
they're gonna play back the stuff you
said and they're going to try to get you
to take less if you want to maximize the
value of that pick
you don't want to take cards off the
table that's all i'm saying i don't
believe what he said
but if i was another gm negotiating with
him i would hit him over the head with
what he said
repeatedly and striking striking and
strike and strike
that's what i would do hi i'm mike
tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports